okay
anyone bite here
thank you
um
i'm well how are you good to see you
congratulations i'm so excited
[Music]
uh
hey
um
all of this stuff has been so fast
hello
all right
[Music]
do you
uh
thank you
um
so
okay
[Music]
are you okay
right here
beautiful
okay
no problem
thank you
one two three four five six nine ten
one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
better worse
so
right
definitely
okay yeah john this is a neutral shift
from a policy that the white house has
had and they did tell governors during
their weekly call today that their plan
now is to redistribute vaccines
if a certain governor does not order
their full allocation that week
basically what they've done so far with
the federal government is each week they
tell governors how much
how many doses they should expect their
states
for example but if the state does not
order that full dose or that full
allocation as some of them have not been
doing
in recent weeks now that you're starting
to see that supply
outstroked that demand here in the
united states
that we have just a few months ago the
white house now says
will still be based on the state's
population and if one week estate
say for example alabama does not work
their full allocation
they'll still get that full allocation
the next week it's not actually going
to change their numbers but john this is
notable because remember just about a
month ago that the michigan
of their vaccines
so
i was like
um
[Music]
hi everyone
[Music]
it's been a while i feel like somebody
taller than you may have been in here
more recently see uh well happy uh
what day is today tuesday happy tuesday
to all of you we haven't been in here
since last tuesday
so just a couple of items for all of you
at the top
i wanted to provide a brief update on
the situation at our southern border
after four years of an immigration
system rooted in destructive and chaotic
policies
president biden is taking the challenge
head-on and is building a fair
orderly and humane immigration system
that's our objective
after coming into office our
administration immediately jumped into
action
to address the influx of migrants at the
border something that began during
and was exacerbated by the trump
administration
and wanted to provide a couple of data
pieces of data you may have seen but
they've come out since
the last time we had a briefing in here
at the end of march there were more than
5 000 children in customs and border
protection
patrol stations today that number is
approximately
six hundred the amount of time children
spend in cbp facilities is down by 75
percent
from 131 hours at the end of march to
under
30 hours now and just yesterday the
department of homeland security
announced that it will begin the process
of reuniting a number of families
who were separated by the policies of
the previous administration
clearly we're not done there's a lot of
work ahead migration is a dynamic and
evolving challenge but the president has
a plan
and we're working on implementing it
just a few more brief updates for you
as you know friday is jobs day here we
are again and to mark the occasion i
wanted to convey to all of you that we
are going to be welcoming in treasury
secretary janet yellen to the briefing
room on friday to provide an update to
all of you and take some questions
and throughout this week the president
the vice president cabinet members and
other administration officials
are fanning out across the country
milwaukee as part of this we'll also
have secretary vilsack
joining us in the briefing room tomorrow
to talk about the vital child nutrition
proposals in the american
families plan um finally
today jeff science and members of our
coveted response team
held their weekly meeting with our
nation's governors this week over 29
million doses
will go out across all of our channels
with two-thirds of those doses
going to jurisdictions and one-third to
federal channels
jeff reiterated the federal government's
commitments to help expand access to the
vaccine boost vaccine confidence
and help states with the unique needs
their unique needs in this vaccination
effort see why don't you kick us off
um the president's token speech this
afternoon to give a
preview of what he's expected to say
what should the american company expect
to hear from him
um and any new updates to the white
house policies regarding
uh mask wearing or testing
here on campus now that the cdc's have
adjusted their
their guidelines last week for fully
vaccinated americans sure
well in terms of the president's remarks
later this afternoon i've been doing
this long enough not to get too far
ahead of him
but i know there's been some reporting
out there so
you all and the american people can
expect to hear an update from the
president
on uh our goals for vaccinating
americans uh
by middle of this summer also
some more updates on our plans to make
the vaccine more available and
accessible
across the country and certainly some
information about what people can expect
once they get vaccinated and in terms of
your second question
we are working our team here is working
uh to uh determine how we will apply
the cdc guidelines that will constantly
be updated as you all know
to uh our efforts and the work we do
here in the white house now
there wasn't there weren't
recommendations or weren't there wasn't
uh
guidance given on workplace use right so
we're really talking about
uh wearing a mask outside i think when i
leave the white house i take my mask off
um if i'm coming back into the white
house sometimes i put it back on when
i'm
taking the walk just to save some time
but in terms of the number of people who
will be
in the building and uh how we will apply
we're still working through that
internally
again there are some reports out of iran
we believe that over the weekend uh
potential uh
uh deal for the release of some u.s
hostages
there i know the state department has
contested that report but just sort of
as a
as a matter of principle is the
president
open to eight dollars for hostages deal
essentially ransom pendants to free
prisoners or see what
does it need to be a part of a broader
path with the iranians
well our policy as a us government has
not changed on ransom
but i will tell you that uh discussions
uh to bring home
americans who are held in iran are
something that are raised
uh that is raised uh at the highest
level through discussions obviously
those are indirect
those are often indirect discussions or
we have our own channels of course
and they are separate from the nuclear
discussions in vienna
but it is a commitment and a desire by
this administration to certainly bring
those hostages back but reports over the
weekend
that an agreement had been reached to
exchange prisoners uh was not true
as i said we always raised this issue
but there's no agreement at this time
to on the release of these four
americans one final one uh
more than a hundred days in the
administration uh when you're up here
at the administration you've announced
the domestic violence experience that
you do
uh give an update on sort of where that
is and what will the final
product that review be sure let me give
you an update on that
uh so it's as you noted seek on uh that
we announced uh early on
that we would uh be undergoing a
domestic violent
uh extremism review through the nsd
through the national security team
uh and we announced that during the
president's first week uh we i can
report that we completed our policy
review in 100 days we allotted
for it uh and right now and this review
of course tackled domestic terrorism
from a range of angles and was comprised
of input from various agencies across
government
so the stage we're in now is that we are
taking uh we're learning taking a look
at what
uh what occurred during that review uh
lessons that we've learned and ensuring
that the policy responses
uh that we've been discussing and
developing are the right ones uh that's
going to take a little bit of time
our ultimate goal from this review has
always been to develop a strategy that
will convey to the american people
an overarching sense of how we'll be
taking on the threat posed by domestic
terrorism something the president has
talked about as one of the greatest
threats
we face i anticipate an update on that
and the policy recommendations will be
weeks uh not months but at this point
that's the stage of the process
go ahead thank you john um just about
secretary clinton's comments yesterday
about russia the g7 he said that uh the
united states wants a more stable and
predictable relationship with russia
um secretary blinken okay i think you
said secretary clinton or that's what i
heard but
okay and uh and i was um i was wondering
what does russia really have to do to
make that happen
considering the navalny situation
considering the russian
aggression of the ukrainian border how
do you have a stable and predictable
relationship
well our relationship with russia
includes uh
us voicing concerns where we have them
taking actions and putting consequences
in place
when actions warrant as we have in uh
in the treatment of alexey novolni as we
did in reaction to
the engagement or the hacking of our own
election here in the united states
at the same time we do think there are
areas where we can continue to work
together on this is
how historically national security
relationships and diplomatic
relationships
have worked around the world so i think
what we are sending a message of
is that we are not looking to escalate
the relationship uh in
in terms of rhetoric or actions uh we
are of course we reserve the right to
put in place consequences should their
actions warrant
and we want to have a stable
relationship where we will work together
in areas where it is constructive as it
as
might as there might be an opportunity
as it relates to the iran negotiations
as an example
and we will continue to voice concerns
as we have them
and one on um sharing ip data
um because uh the administration seems
to be under
increasing pressure to share ip data
from doctors and even some global
leaders
dr fauci recently uh joined industry
uh during a television interview to say
that that is perhaps not the best way to
get shots and arms
and i was just wondering what the
official white house view is on that
i i wouldn't say that's an exact
characteristic characterization of his
uh
comments or remarks that he made but i
will say that uh i would expect we'll
have something to say
about this once the wto session uh gets
underway
obviously ambassador thai uh is uh would
be making a recommendation to the
president that's not something that has
happened at this point and obviously
just for people to understand for
everyone to understand this process
because sometimes it's short handed in a
um
on television or in other places what
we're talking about is the united states
position
uh it's a wto process and what
ultimately happens here will not be up
to the united states alone this is a
waiver that there would have to be
agreement
among wto members on i think what i saw
dr fauci's
comments speak to as well which is
certainly our position is that
our objective is to save lives by
producing as much supply as possible
and getting shots and arms around the
world in the most effective way
and we're determining what the right
steps are to do exactly that okay thank
you and
one last one on india i know i've been
asking you constantly about that but
it's obviously really important is the
administration doing all it can
to help india well let me give you an
update and i know we've provided a few
of those but i don't think we've done a
substantive one here on what has
happened or
or what the recent shipments have been
so six air shipments funded by
usaid have departed the united states
five of which have already arrived in
india
these flights include health supplies
oxygen oxygen supplies
n95 masks rapid diagnostic tests
and medicine and these are a lot of the
components that the indian government
has expressed a
vital need for more flights are on the
way with total assistance expected to
exceed 100 million
dollars at the request of the government
of india usaid
provided these urgently needed supplies
to the indian red cross
to ensure they reach those most in need
as quickly as possible
in terms of oxygen support which as you
all know is a big component of what they
need right now
we're talking about oxygen cylinders so
usaid delivered approximately 1500
cylinders
that will remain in india and can
repeatedly be refilled
at local supply centers with more plane
loads to come
oxygen concentrators usa ideas sent
approximately 550 oxygen concentrators
to obtain
oxygen from ambient air and usaid has
also delivered a large scale unit to
support up to 20 patients each
of an oxygen generation unit we've also
sent
2.5 million and 95 masks and we have an
additional
12.5 million and 95 masks available
should that request come from the indian
government
and we've directed our own order of
astrazeneca manufacturing supplies to
india
allowing india to make over 20 million
doses we've also provided 1 million
rapid diagnostic tests
and this weekend this past weekend usaid
delivered
20 000 treatment courses of the
anti-viral doug renzovir to help treat
hospitalized patients
and we're also working one of the
questions that's come up is about
assistance and know-how and
cdc experts will work in close
coordination with india's public health
experts
in uh in the following areas laboratory
surveillance and epidemio epidemiology
i'm not a medical expert emergency
response and operations development
uh bioinformatics for genomic sequencing
and modeling
so we are in close touch that's a
summary of what we've done just over the
last several days and we're working to
meet the immediate needs they have now
even as we consider
uh you know when we have astrazeneca
doses available what can happen there
okay go ahead thank you uh you mentioned
secretary ellen is coming on friday she
said in remarks published today that it
may be the full interest rates will have
to rise
somewhat to make sure that our economy
doesn't overheat does president biden
agree with it
i think president trump certainly agrees
with his treasury secretary
but i will say that one of the reasons i
think you're asking this question is
about
inflation concerns and something that we
uh watch closely here
obviously in the treasury department and
in the white house
in close coordination and that is
something where
there's agreement i looked at secretary
yellen's remarks or the ones that i saw
which he also conveyed is how vital it
is to make these investments now and how
important it is for our economy
for investment in research and
development for
uh leveling the play playing field on
the workforce to make exactly this
investment so
of course uh officials who don't work
here in the federal reserve and other
places
closely watch what needs to happen i'm
not going to speak on interest rates
uh but we also take inflationary risk
incredibly seriously and our economic
experts have conveyed that they think
this would be temporary and that the
uh benefits far outweigh the concern
because of course the previous
administration was routinely criticized
for
repeatedly sharing its views on what
rates should do
secretary ellen is expressing her view
on what will happen to race do you think
that this is
an appropriate comment for a treasury
secretary is she expressing an opinion
on what the fed should do when she says
this well i would say of all people
secretary yellen certainly understands
the
independence and the role of federal
reserve um and
i think she was simply answering a
question and conveying how we balance
decision making here
one other thing this week facebook is
going to decide whether or not to
reinstate donald trump's accounts on
facebook and instagram
if he is reinstated is there any change
in strategy that the white house would
put in messaging in other words if he's
on these platforms expressing
his views does that change what you do
at all no
go ahead thank you jen um ahead of the
president's speech today
is there any context or data you can
share
about the holdouts about people who are
still not getting vaccinated or signing
up to get vaccinated
so we can understand if the problem is
access to the vaccine
or hesitancy because they think it's
unsafe
sure well first let me say that what
we've seen is that the more people who
are vaccinated and
today he'll talk about the fact that you
are aware of this data that 150 million
people in this country now have had one
dose adults i should say
105 million have had two doses the more
people who are vaccinated
the the more that confidence increases
and the more people want to get
vaccinated that's not a surprise to us
that was what we anticipated and hoped
for
uh given if your friend or your neighbor
or somebody in your community is
vaccinated
uh it gives you greater confidence about
the efficacy
of the vaccine and maybe you see what
the impact and the benefits are
we always expected we should to be at
this phase
where once we reached that percentage
approximately of
people who were vaccinated once we got
to the point where
it was no longer an issue of access to
supply because we have more than enough
supply
for the american public that it would
become
more and more difficult to meet people
where they are and to reach them
and the biggest factor we've seen
consistently has we always focus on
confidence of course but even with
confidence the biggest challenge is
access
and access can mean a lot of things it
can mean
concern about safety that we've seen
improvements in confidence levels
it can also mean where do you get a
vaccine which is why we've invested so
heavily and the president will talk
about this today
in programs like our pharmacy program
mobile vaccine units
mass vaccination sites partnering with
primary fair
care physicians local doctors etc but
also why we um
announce made the announcement last week
about paid leave so that people can take
a day off of work and they don't have to
worry about losing income we were seeing
that as a factor
so we're constantly evaluating how to
make this easier and more acceptable
accessible but we we knew we'd be at
this point where it would become
more difficult and we've been preparing
for that thank you
i know you've seen the reports about the
fda um
approving the pfizer vaccine for
kids between the ages of 12 and 15. not
yet
not yet but is there anything you can
tell us about how close they might be
and in the meantime
what the administration is doing to
prepare
so that those kids can get the shots
right away sure well i can't get ahead
of the fda process
and certainly in part because we want to
ensure people have confidence in the
safety of vaccines when they make a
decision
but i will say the president will talk a
bit about what preparations we are
making here
to ensure that if a vaccine is approved
if the fires or vaccine is approved by
the fda or others in the future
uh that we make that accessible to
additional
younger populations
on sunday ron klain said that the white
house had invited a group of republican
senators to come talk about
infrastructure
do you have any details about that
meeting including whether the president
will attend
sure so i think he was referring to the
invitation the president made to senator
capito that we announced last week and
and a group of
members she selects uh to come to the
white house
since congress is on senate is on recess
this week we anticipate that meeting
being next week and it just hasn't been
locked in yet on the day
and who will be included in that group
of attendees uh
but that's what he was referring to this
weekend uh but we don't have an update
quite yet as we have one we'll we'll
share that with all of you
good question thanks jen i just want to
give you a chance to respond to the
accusations that the
american federation of teachers the
country's largest
second largest teachers union influenced
the cdc's guidelines on reopening
schools yet
republican senator tom cotton saying
that this is evidence of a politicized
public health agency
answering at the beckham called the
teachers union so how does the white
house respond
well i would say first that's false
let's take a step back
and talk about how the cdc works the cdc
it's actually long-standing best
practice for the cdc to engage with
organizations and groups
that are going to be impacted by
guidance and recommendations issued
by the agency it doesn't mean they are
taking everything they want or even a
percentage of what they want but it's
important to understand the
implementation components they do so to
ensure
that recommendations are feasible and
that they adequately address the safety
and well-being of the individuals
the guidance is aimed to protect protect
so the cdc engaged with around 50
stakeholders that are on the front lines
in this pandemic
and have requisite perspective for the
guidance
the president reiterated last week that
july 4th is the target date
for returning american life to something
closer to normal
can you just define what exactly closer
to normal is
what does that look like for the average
american well
first the president will have more about
his updated
goals that we have as an administration
by that july
timeline that he'll talk about later
this afternoon uh you know what he's
talked about is
if you're giving incentives for people
to be vaccinated to understand what the
benefits are what the benefits are of
getting a shot or two
shots uh and one of the things he's
talked about for some time
since his prime time address before the
joint address was
people being able to gather in their
backyard and have a barbecue
and obviously we follow the advice and
guidelines of our health and medical
experts but if we
increase the number of people who are
vaccinated around the country in
communities
that will enable people to do more
things that they're used to
so the guidance last week of course said
that if you're vaccinated
uh you don't have to wear a mask outside
as long as you're not in a crowd
it also said if you're vaccinated you
can go a lot of places
if you're wearing a mask and you can
feel safe and comfortable uh but he'll
have more to say later this afternoon
about the july timeline
okay one more question about since we've
been talking a lot about the refugee cap
something that's
not entirely uh similar but certainly
related the afghan special immigrant
visa program is facing this
backlog of thousands and thousands of
applicants and of course
time is running out and the withdrawal
beginning over the weekend so
can you just kind of summarize what
exactly is the plan
to address this backlog before
all us troops withdrawal you know
kristin it's a great question it's an
important program the president talked
about of course has talked about in the
past
and he is committed to i would say the
state department would oversee
uh the process for those visas so i
would point you to them
is there a plan or is the plan still
being drafted uh i don't have an update
on the plan
i will just convey to you that uh
ensuring that people who have been
partners to the united states who have
played such a vital role uh who are
eligible can apply and that we do that
our embassy
of course is is remaining there and a
presence there as well
uh but they would be the right agency to
talk about processing and timeline and
what that looks like
like you guys might surge volunteers or
staff to the embassy in kabul to help
it's a great question but i would again
point to the state department because
the personnel would come from there
go ahead hello rpg captain since it is
now going to be set at 62
500 this fiscal year but president biden
says he doesn't think we'll actually get
there so
where does he think will be by september
30th on the number of refugees
well i i would say first that um you
know what's important about this cap
is one that he wanted to as he said in
his statement yesterday he wanted to
eliminate any lingering doubt
from any refugee across the world that
the united states wasn't a country that
would welcome refugees in to apply under
the biden harris administration that's
exactly who we want to be
but setting this cap the objective is
twofold one
is it helps send a message that message
to the world i just conveyed
but also it helps get the muscles
working that have atrophied over the
last several years when we were not
welcoming in
many many refugees so uh this is not
just a federal government or u.s
government uh
a you know effort uh there are so many
organizations who play incredible
roles in the united states and around
the world they have been understaffed
they've been under resourced
and some of our success will depend on
the ability to rebuild those systems
so yes we will not it is unlikely we
will meet that 62
500 cap it is actually historically
rarely is that the ca are the caps meant
or met i should say
but our objective is to get those
muscles working again and send a clear
message to the world
and right now the number is still around
2 000. that was the latest we had gotten
so it just was
is there an update on what that number
is right now i can see if there's an
updated number we have had people start
coming in
uh because we resumed the flights and
because we
uh overturned the policy that prevented
refugees from applying from the middle
east and from
africa we're constantly updating those
numbers but i'll see if there's a number
to update you on
and then on what jeff zions told the
governors today on that call that now
the white house will redistribute
vaccine allocations if a state doesn't
order the full allocation they get that
week
can you just walk us through what
changed in that policy since
last month when the michigan governor
made a direct appeal to the president to
get more vaccines for her state
she was told that couldn't happen at the
time so can you just walk us through the
thinking
sure this policy change sure well first
we are always evaluating how to ensure
we're getting more
supply out to uh the country and out to
the american people more shots and arms
so even just a few weeks ago we were in
a different phase of our vaccination
effort when supply was more constrained
and states
for the most part were ordering at or
near their full
allocation so what this announcement
does and what
what jeff conveyed to the governors is
they can still order it's up to them
they can order up to their full
allocation based on population
they can also order less than their full
allocation
and the less the the doses that are not
than given to that state will then go
into
kind of an overarching supply that could
then be distributed to other states by
population
now that same governor could the
following week decide to
order back to their maximum allocation
so it gives flexibility week by week
but it's really just an indication that
we're in a different phase now that we
were than we were even
a couple of weeks ago in terms of access
to supply and we want to ensure
the doses are uh that we free up on
ordered unused uh
and unordered doses and last question
does the president still think that we
will get to hurt immunity in the u.s
this calendar year well the president's
uh
we we try to leave the predictions of
when we will reach
any definition by medical and health
experts of that term
i will say that what the president will
talk about today
is what percentage of the population uh
he hopes
uh to be vaccinated by this summer that
obviously is a step forward and what we
can do from an operational standpoint
from the white house from jeff
science and arkova team is continue to
operationalize getting these shots out
into the country but assessments of
what that will mean we will leave to our
health and medical experts and apply our
guidance
accordingly go to karen jen to follow up
on that question then from caitlin the
president was asked about that yesterday
and said there's a debate about it and
on the call with the governors today we
obtained audio of it dr fauci seemed to
downplay the notion of herd immunity
he called it an elusive concept of a
number so
is that no longer the administration's
goal does the white house not believe
that's possible is this
a deliberate shift away from that again
it's a great question i just don't want
to answer and i know we typically have a
briefing with our health and medical
team on tuesdays so
you may have to wait for the next one or
the next time one of these doctors is on
television to talk about the definition
of it
but what our objective is is of course
to vaccinate as much of the population
as quickly as we can and the definition
of what that will mean for communities
what that will mean for going back to
normal we look forward to applying that
believe me we all want to
take our masks off inside and we all
want to return back to normal and we
understand the frustration of the public
but we will leave the definition of that
to our health and medical experts
and is the administration planning to
phase out fema's
mass vaccine sites in favor of focusing
more on
local level community health centers the
mobile centers that we've been talking
about
uh is it not effective to be using those
mass vaccine sites anymore
at this point in the campaign it's more
effective in some places than others so
we announced a couple of new mass
vaccination sites last thursday or
friday
there are some places where those max
vaccination sites
that's a mouthful for some reason have
not stayed open
and we evaluate working in coordination
with of course governors
local health and medical experts on
what's working we look at the data and
see what's working
and there are some programs like our
pharmacy program we initially on
launched it as a pilot with just a
couple thousand pharmacies right now
it's over forty 000 or even greater than
that
because that we've seen is very
effective we're partnering with uh local
primary care physicians
in part because through our data we see
that
uh people trust their local doctors and
that if it's easy if you know you're
going there to get your checkup that
that is an easy place to
do vaccinations so there are certain
parts of the country or certain
communities where we still have mass
vaccination sites we'll continue to open
them
but we're constantly evaluating the best
delivery mechanisms and if something is
not the most effective one we will make
changes
uh go ahead thank you does the
administration want or does it already
have some plans
being uh formulated to allow in foreign
businesses this summer in the same way
the eu
is pretty clearly said that so we're
gonna open the doors uh they have
um but we uh again this is a case which
i know is
endlessly frustrating to people and i
will acknowledge that uh where we will
uh rely on the advice and the
recommendations
by our health and medical experts on uh
what is safe for the american
public and they are constantly
evaluating that but i can't
get ahead of their process uh and what i
anticipate in terms of any changes to
travel restrictions
okay thank you and another one um
against the background of fighting which
is going on now in helmand in
afghanistan
after the us troops left the taliban and
government forces uh
started in um what is what is what is
going to be the president's message
if this specter of a taliban takeover
which is obviously
quite possible happens after september
what's going to be his message to the
afghan people
you know including the many who probably
don't support the taliban is it going to
be essentially
look we're sorry this is not your affair
we're out of here i mean
is there going to be anything more than
that that he can say
to them well i would say that when the
president gave his speech
on our decision to pull troops out of
afghanistan
he talked about the fact that we will
continuing we will continue of course to
have an over the horizon
presence that we will continue to
provide a range of humanitarian
and other direct assistance we will
still have an
embassy at this point in afghanistan and
a presence there
at a diplomatic level so uh what
the announcement we made was about
removing troops because it is in the
best interest of our own
national security but uh he believes in
diplomacy believes that is the right
path forward
uh and we'll we will continue to support
that and work with our international
partners around the world to move
forward
could he foresee a day when when the us
and the u.s embassy and
the united states deals with the taliban
government which is
ruling against that obviously we watch
closely and work
closely with our partners in the region
on what the future looks like but i'm
not going to get ahead of the status in
afghanistan
go ahead yeah a couple questions uh the
white house
said the president wants to see progress
on the american jobs plan
by the end of this month and passage by
the summer does that same time frame
apply to the family's plan that he
released last week
that's a great question i mean we
obviously just introduced it
it's introduced it some period of time
after we introduced the american jobs
plan i expect we'll have
discussions with members of congress
about components of each
different members have uh support or
more excited about different components
of different parts of
the plan but i don't have a new timeline
to set for the american family's plan
well with those
uh negotiations and the meeting that you
referenced yeah uh coming up with
republican senators
uh you mentioned old talk infrastructure
is he also gonna talk
the family's plan with those senators
when he holds that meeting well this
particular meeting i mean there's
there's dozens and dozens of meeting
engagements phone calls conversations
that are happening
on a regular basis and a couple of um
you know
secretary pete uh buddha judge is going
to be briefing the congressional
progressive caucus this week on the
package as well as speaking
at leader hoyer's committee chair weekly
meeting our jobs cabinet continues to
make one-on-one calls to members on both
sides of the aisle
and some of them are also in districts
this week amplifying with members
our legislative affairs team is doing
briefings and having dozens of calls and
engagements
as well this one particular meeting um
is related to a counter proposal that
senator capito
made which is focused on the american
jobs plan
so i would expect that to be a primary
focus of the meeting
but there will be a range of meetings
about uh the proposals the american
families plan
as well and different proposals that the
president has put on the table at this
point uh when you think about getting
these plans passed through congress
are you envisioning both plans being
combined into one bill i mean is that
what the white house favors or
separately what's the position right now
we're open to a range of mechanisms uh
for
the president's ideas moving forward but
exactly what you're talking about is
part of the discussion we're going to
have with members of congress and
there's an openness to
smaller package to different components
moving forward together
we will leave those mechanics to leaders
in congress
but what we're discussing with them is
where we can find agreements on many of
the proposals and ideas the president
has put forward
a question on the family's plan during
the campaign president
biden proposed free tuition uh
four-year colleges and universities for
students whose families
earn 125 000 or less his family's plan
released last week as you know
only offers free tuition to students to
attend two-year
community colleges why did he not go
through with that larger plan for free
schooling and universities in college
and why was it limited to just
community colleges well let me first say
uh well the american families plan as a
historic investment in education and
child care
uh free universal pre-k uh for
uh for three and four-year-olds across
the country which we know would have a
huge impact
50 or 50 percent more likely to graduate
from high school if you go to preschool
as opposed to daycare
and two years of community college but
this is not the totality of what the
president hopes to do on education
this is a a significant investment a
historic
investment that he's proposing but uh
we're less than
i know 100 less than 107 days i know we
are into the administration go ahead
thanks ben that the president of
education
believes that public schools should
require that students get vaccinated
um once folks under 16 if you're
available to get back there but that's
guys
whatever the next couple of months uh i
i don't uh
it's not my understanding that we're
putting in new requirements here from
the federal government
i would expect the department of
education will work with local schools
and school districts on
implementation and how to keep students
and and uh
and teachers safe warehouses come out in
support of teachers unions were already
pretty public about the fact that they
want students under 16 to get vaccinated
if they can get vaccinated and are
eligible to get vaccinated
i don't have any anticipation of
requirements from the federal government
at this point in time but obviously
we'll look to our health and medical
experts on any additional guidance to
provide but even like passing support on
social media i know the president's very
pro-union
but we just have to take your treatment
all the time would at least invite them
here to have conversations so do you
anticipate that
president biden would at least come out
on the side of the union for this
specific issue
i wouldn't i would say that the
president is going to abide by the
advice and guidance of health and
medical experts
and certainly we put out public health
information and we've put out mitigation
steps that schools can take
in order to protect their school
population
uh but i don't have anything else to
predict for you at this point in time
just one more sure i just want to go to
the white house after you respond to the
backlash liz cheney has been getting
recently for coming out and saying that
you know honestly
won the election fair and square and
that the republicans are saying that
that's not true is a bit of hogwash and
um obviously figuring out artistic
liberties there but uh
the west side responds to the
republicans kind of ganging up on her or
having a negative reaction to that
well i would say first that um you know
the republican party seems to be
spending a lot of blood sweat and tears
trying to figure out
where they stand and what they stand for
and
that's their prerogative but our focus
is on
uh and how we're spending our time is on
defeating the pandemic growing our
economy
building on that for the long run and
it's no secret
that the president doesn't see eye to
eye on many policies with uh
congresswoman cheney but
his view is that the american people
elected him and
also many people representing congress
representing them in congress to
solve problems for them and uh he's
going to continue to seek civility even
when he disagrees uh go oh let me go let
me just get around and then i'll come
back to you if that's okay go ahead
jonathan
okay thanks uh president biden's
recently named
uh nominated somebody to run the federal
motor carrier safety administration
first would be his first senate
confirmed administrator in years
then agency has been criticized for
years by trace the traffic safety
advocates for not doing anything
especially if the truck safety was
supposed to regulate for example since
2016 they have a proposed rule to limit
the speed of trucks which hasn't been
acted on
in five years did the president discuss
safety when he nominated
her to take over the agency uh
i'm not sure there's been a discussion
with her directly obviously if she was
selected or nominated to serve in this
particular role but
it's my understanding that the
department of education of
transportation i should say sorry is
examining
available tools to address exactly the
problems that you've outlined
which could include awareness training
and supporting healthy practices
preventive
medical intervention and regulation but
we'd really defer to them on their
processes
the president also recently named three
people to the chemical safety board
which had been down to one of five board
members for the last year
uh what do you make that some of his
early earliest appointments
or nominations well as you touch on
jonathan uh the
the chemical safety board has a
significant backlog of cases pending
uh currently only has one board member
out of five the president wanted to fill
the vacancies or hopes to fill the
vacancies
quickly to make sure the board is able
to fulfill its responsibilities
and review these cases in a timely
manner and certainly the impact
communities across the country
one last question is a bunch of
lawmakers including one i cover
who would love to still see another
round of stimulus checks
or direct pain even every month till the
pandemic ends
or is that something that it hasn't been
either the president's new proposals but
that's something that
could be on the table well i mean first
i would say that in the president's new
proposal he does call for
uh an extension of the historic uh a
historic expansion i should say
extension of the child tax credit
and if passed the families of tens of
millions of children will continue to
get regular payments that total up to
three thousand
dollars per year for kids age six and
over and thirty six hundred for kids
under six uh obviously we're continuing
to evaluate what their needs are uh
to continue to get the pandemic under
control put people back to work but we
think that's also a proposal that will
have a long-term benefit
it could be another round of direct
payments in one of these bills
we'll see what members of congress
propose um but those are not free
uh go ahead in the back john my first
question
is on ambassadorships uh many
uh key uh picks uh have not been made
for these roles um which serve as a
representation of american university
overseas the united states has never had
a lesbian woman or transgender person as
an ambassador
is the president missing an opportunity
to name those firsts
well given we haven't named uh many
ambassadors quite yet and we hope too
soon stay tuned um uh certainly the
president looks to
ensuring that the people representing
him not just in the united states but
around the world
represent the diversity of the country
and that certainly includes
people who are lgbtq a member of the
transgender community
uh i don't know i don't have any
predictions for you on that front um
but i will say that he's uh soon i'm
sure we'll be evaluating some
uh recommended nominees coming from our
personnel office and our national
security team to fill some important
posts
and he of course always looks at
diversity could you define soon a little
bit further what was it
like days months weeks well i think it
depends on when the president makes some
decisions and
he'll continue to consider a range of
options for a lot of the positions that
are out there
and still remain uh vacant i will say
having served the state department for a
couple of years there are incredible
career service employees who are serving
in these embassies around the world who
are representing the united states and
our values um
that continues to be the case but of
course we're eager to have ambassadors
in place and confirmed
to represent the president and the vice
president
go ahead thank you my second inquiry is
um
on the president's speech to congress
last week
he told transgender youth he has the
mass
and the president made these remarks in
the context of states
enacting laws against transgender youth
including a
measure the titan city governor signed
just today
requiring parental notification on lgbt
lgbtq
inclusive school curriculum the
president's inclusion of transgender
people in his speech to congress is
significant in and of itself
but what will the president having their
backs look like going forward
well certainly the president has put in
place uh has signed executive orders
he's also
used the power of the bully pulpit and
his presidency to convey that
transgender rights or human rights and
that is his belief in the view of his
administration and how he expects
policies to be implemented that includes
ensuring ensuring that transgender
youth have the opportunity to play
sports and to be treated
um equally in states across the country
so um he will look to members of his
administration
to implement uh what his view is and
what he what his value is as president
would you rule out legal action against
these laws going forward as part of that
i will leave you that to the department
of justice
um go ahead in the back thank you jim
very much a couple of questions and then
another one from a colleague
uh will president biden give an update
on sharing vaccines
with the words today and like for
example is there any consideration
to let go uh the unordered vaccine
supply that will be redistributed here
also to other countries is the
consideration for that
well our focus right now is on allowing
the
um available the astrazeneca vaccine
supply that we have
expected over the next couple of months
going through a process to determine
where we can get provide those vaccines
so right now we have zero doses
available
we hope to have about 10 million in the
coming weeks and about an additional 50
million in the coming months
and there's a process internally that's
determining where those doses will go
but that's really where our focus is at
this moment
but we will continue to evaluate ways to
increase and expand
global vaccine supply around the world
beyond that so does the white house
believe they could be doing more
or faster to help closing the gap
between vaccination
in rich countries and the rest of the
world or
do you believe the 60 million dollar
doses of extrazenica
are enough i don't think i said it was
enough i think i said that that is where
our focus is at this moment
but we will continue to look for ways to
our objective
is to be contributing a big contributing
component
of providing as much global supply
in as cost-effective manner as possible
and that's what we're evaluating now
so the 60 million is what we know we
will have available in the coming months
you just went through a list of help
that administration is giving to india
and there is a great coordination to
help
india why are not we are not seeing the
same
response or engagement from this white
house uh with brazil a lot of
experts around the world are saying
brazil is leaving a humanitarian
catastrophe and there are more
death in brazil than in india so why
such a difference and we know that
brazil also asked for oxygen
sedatives uh is the white house or is
the administration considering
sending additional help to brazil well
recognizing that the fight against kova
19 is a global struggle
we are in partner working to partner
with the government of brazil and the
pan-american health organization to
finalize access to 20 million dollars
worth of critical
intubation medications needed to save
brazilian
lives these medications will come from
the us government
a facilitated purchase and from the u.s
strategic national stockpile
the support is being offered to offset
global supply shortages and when it will
enable brazil to
receive sufficient medication to meet
their immediate
hospital needs so that is an effort
that's underway has not yet been
finalized but we are working
in partnership with the government of
brazil on that still being the least to
receive
the astrazeneca there are a range of
requests we've had from around the world
we're evaluating those needs now uh but
i can't get ahead of that process
can i just ask one more from my
colleague from bristol segovia uh
mvs radio from mexico uh he's asking
that he's saying that at least 20 people
have been killed in protests
they have been going on in colombia for
a week now
nearly a thousand cases of police
brutality have been reported
is the president being briefed about the
situation in colombia
and what is the white house response
i'll have to ask our national security
team uh on the latest
um engagement we've had with the
colombian government and others on that
and i will get back to you with a
comment
quickly one last one sorry uh does the
white house believe the former president
uh president trump should be allowed to
return to facebook and instagram
it's a decision maybe being made by an
independent oversight board
um beyond that we don't have any further
comment go ahead thanks jen i want to
ask you a few about
taxes real quick um yeah
taxes goes for the last one in the back
right that's right that's right
on the salt cap some congressional
democrats are saying
no salt cap repeal no deal with the
president
um as it goes forward with his tax plan
democrats up on the hill
we know the position that the white
house has had for several weeks now so
i'm wondering
what's more likely at this point for the
white house to move towards these
congressional democrats
or do or congressional democrats in this
case to
back off their position eventually we
don't know yet this is democracy in
action
this is what's fun about this uh we are
having discussions we are certainly
aware of the
uh members um who have conveyed a strong
view
about the salt uh deduction uh and
uh we'll have that discussion with them
where you already hear their proposals
some of them have put some proposals
forward
i think what we're factoring in here in
the discussion is that
i think as you and i have talked about
before this is not a revenue raiser
so it would be additional cost that's
okay
but then you have to determine either
how to pay for it what other things are
cut out
certainly that would be a part of the
discussion you heard from the president
yesterday about the step up in basis he
sort of laid out the argument as to why
that should be eliminated
for wealthy individuals upon inheritance
essentially lowers the capital gains
burden the
tax foundation gave the gave an example
100 million in gains they say
that the tax on that would be 61 percent
we know the white house's position that
the wealthiest need to pay their fair
share i think anyone would agree that
100 million dollars in gains is a lot of
money
but i guess the question is whether or
not a 61
tax bill is reasonable does the white
house believe that's reasonable
i i'd have to talk to our number
crunchers about the specific
example you gave i i don't know what
percentage of people have a hundred
million dollars in capital gains maybe
you know that sounds like
quite a lot to me uh but the fundamental
value here the president is conveying is
that uh
his proposals are about and making a
historic investment in education
in child care that's going to make us
more competitive to compete with china
to bring more women back into the
workforce he's proposed a way to pay for
it
that's going to impact as it relates to
capital gains 0.3 percent
of the population and the example you
gave i don't even know that's probably
0.00 i don't know what percentage of the
population
that's his proposal there are other
proposals that can be put forward but i
have to look at the
statistics to with our team to give an
evaluation on that
in the american family american families
plan it calls for financial banks
and financial institutions to report
account floats
the treasury department said it would
add information about aggregate account
outflows and inflows basically money
coming
in and out of one's bank account and the
question is
there's a concern that maybe that's the
federal government having too
big of an insight you know what's going
into your bank account and what's coming
out of your bank account
along with that i would just make filing
your taxes a whole lot
tougher it's already a pain it's already
open
is that too much for the federal
government to know what's coming in and
what's coming out of your bank
what this proposal is as you know but
just to explain to others
is uh cracking down more on ensuring
people are paying the tax
uh the taxes they should be paying on
their income at the rates they should be
paying them at
uh there's a lot of imp there's a number
of implementation mechanisms for that
and obviously the irs can
outline that more specifically than i
can but again this is a proposal about
how to pay for historic investments in
child care
and education if people have alternative
proposals that don't raise taxes on
people making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
that will help pay for this we're quite
open to them
mitch mcconnell um put forth or
basically said that
republicans would be willing to go
forward with the 600 billion dollar
infrastructure plan
no do not touch the corporate tax
structure that is currently in place
the white house's response to that is
what
well i think one there's a counter
proposal that we're happy that we're
going to have a discussion about with
senator capito
next week there's lots of discussions at
a staff level
i think the question there is is he
suggesting we don't need to pay for the
proposal
it sounds like it unless there's an
alternative
essentially people who use which again
as we've as we've talked about
user fees um would put the burden on the
backs of the american people
would in short would make it so that
people driving a car it depends on what
use the user fees are
right if it's the uh basically a tax for
the number of miles you drive as an
example or other user fees
that means people making fifty thousand
a hundred thousand hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year
are going to have to pay for these
proposals we have a difference of you
on the pay force our view is that the
one percent of people who are making
over uh four hundred thousand 000 a year
can afford to pay a little bit more
but we can have a discussion about that
thanks everyone
oh